لقد حصلنا على ما يُتوقع أن يكون
جزءًا أساسيًا من قضية الحكومة
ضد دونالد ترامب ، وهو تسجيل صوتي حقيقي
للرئيس السابق يتحدث كما لو كان يعرض
وثيقة سرية للغاية حول خطط الحرب الأمريكية
ضد إيران مع أشخاص ليسوا على
علم بذلك.  موجود ، ناهيك عما
بداخله في لحظة فقط على شبكة سي إن إن ، سوف
تسمع ما سيستمع إليه المحلفون يومًا ما
تم تسجيل التسجيل قبل عامين من الصيف في يوليو
2021 في نادي الرئيس السابق في
بيدمينستر نيوجيرسي ، ستسمع بوضوح
الرئيس السابق وهو
يتحدث  وفقًا للائحة
الاتهام التي قدمها المستشار الخاص ، كان من
بينهم كاتب يعمل في الناشر Mark Meadows
Memoir واثنين من
موظفي ترامب ، وكان الرئيس على علم بأنه
تم تسجيله ، فهذه هي
المرة الأولى التي تُعرض فيها علنًا ،
فهؤلاء أشخاص مرضى سيئون.  كانت هذه هي
الإشارة التي تعرفها ضدك جيدًا ، لقد
بدأت بشكل صحيح ما تتحدث
عنه ميلي ، لقد كنت تحاول أن تفعل لا ، لقد
كانوا يحاولون فعل ذلك قبل أن
تقسم اليمين على هذا النحو محاولًا
قلب حياتك بشكل جيد مع ميلي
آه دعني  أرى أنني سأريكم
مثالًا قال
إنني أردت مهاجمة إيران ،
أليس هذا رائعًا لدي كومة كبيرة من
الأوراق ، لقد ظهر هذا الشيء للتو ، هذا هو الشخص الذي
قدموه لي ، هذا غير رسمي
لكنهم قدموا لي  كان هذا هو ، وكان هذا هو
قسم الدفاع فيه ،
نظرنا إلى البعض ، وكان هذا هو
ولم يتم القيام به من قبلي ، وكان هذا هو كل أنواع
الأشياء ، إنها صفحات طويلة
انتظر لحظة ، فلنرى هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم ، أنا فقط  وجدت أنه ليس مدهشًا ،
فهذا يفوز بحالتي تمامًا كما تعلم ، إلا أنها تشبه إلى حد
كبير في
النهاية
هناك نظرة سرية للمعلومات على
هذا الذي تهاجمه وستقوم هيلاري بطباعة
ذلك طوال الوقت الذي تعلم أنه
يجب أن أرسله إلى أنتوني وينر
بواسطة  الطريق ليس بهذه الروعة ، نعم كنت
أقول فقط لأننا كنا نتحدث
عنه وأنت تعلم أنه قال إنه يريد
مهاجمة إيران ، وقد
تم ذلك من قبل الجيش الذي أعطي
لي ،
وأعتقد أنه من المحتمل أن نحصل عليه وعلينا أن
نرى  نعم ،
أرى هذا الرئيس الذي كان بإمكاني القيام به في
العام الماضي ، لا لا يمكنني معرفة ذلك ، لكن هذا نعم ،
أليس هذا مثيرًا للاهتمام ، إنه رائع جدًا ،
أعني أنه يبدو أننا هنا
ولم أفعل ،
وربما أنت  لم تصدقني تقريبًا
ولكنك الآن تصدقني لا ، أعتقد
أنه أمر لا يصدق ، أليس كذلك ، لقد
أحضروا بعض الكولا في مكانها